Michael Wilbon is the co-host of the
popular show pardon the interruption and
Mike joins us now on the program Michael
how are you I'm good how are you
well you should be good capitals one
aren't you are you rooting for the
Capitals to to do something dramatic or
you do a Blackhawks fan I'm not one of
the guys just because he moved somewhere
even though it's been 38 years in DC no
I am I am rooting for the Capitals
because the Blackhawks aren't involved
you know I'm rooting for them they did
something dramatic last night I hear I
was flying they get to Oakland and I
couldn't see the game but I'm glad the
Capitals one and even didn't maybe
they'll be some drama in that series do
you respect Bryce Harper here he is
playing with the Nationals
he's from Vegas and he's all in on the
Vegas Golden Knights that's all he said
yeah yeah I'm not a person into adopting
teams to me is the funniest thing I
guess it wouldn't be funny if you've
lived somewhere forever Bryce has lived
in DC for what what is this sixth season
maybe and he's not that old anyways
Bryce Harper's still like 24 25 that's
supposed to be what he does you know
this is now if the biggest golden guys
weren't involved he was cheering for his
stuff is fairly newly adopted t5 he's
from Vegas that's the theme good for him
and anybody in Washington
who's there anything about that or terms
of saritha it needs to shut up DC is
kind of underrated for a heartache
aren't they
misery you know Dan it has happened in
the last 20 years yeah I mean for a
while there that was one way back and I
guess you got to be able to so today's
like like hours when DC had some real
winning going on when the Redskins at
won three Super Bowls
when Georgetown had one it's it's been a
while there was no baseball of course
they and the win and the bullets had won
so they were I mean the three they had
time had done pretty well but
in a while I mean and most of it is
defined by the Redskins still who
haven't won since that third one which
is what 1991 so it's it's it's been a
while yeah it doesn't take long to go
from a city where winning is fairly
expected until you know you start
talking about who's choking and how many
years has been and what drought and how
many cities have had X number of
appearances since there's been a win so
yeah I guess it's sneaky it's sneaking
up on people if you're if you're 30
years old you haven't seen any winning
of that thing Michaels covering every
game of the NBA Finals SportsCenter
won't co-hosting pardon the interruption
from the road you can follow him on I
believe is real social media platforms
you're at real Michael Mike will bond
right I guess so okay all right that's
my next part yeah at real no no longer
work like three days ago you might have
had burners but not not anymore yeah no
you know it's really funny and I I do
tweet I evolved in Twitter I'm really
involved in you know Instagram unity
involves like November first I had to
like get a crash course on what that was
what that meant
yeah I'm not knee-deep at this age in
social media at all and so the notion is
Bryan Colangelo who was not that much
younger than me five or six years
younger is he like 52 53 something like
that the notion that you know somebody
in this 50s would be that deep even
professionally in social media and sort
of surprised to me I wonder if he can
keep his job though Mike even if it's
not Brian but it's somebody in his
family if it's if there's a third party
here doesn't it feel like he's exchanged
opinions information with this person
who would then go on social media to
have his back
it depends on how close you're talking
but you know I mean I exchange opinions
were a lot of people certainly my
brother if he even went out and tweeted
it I need to lose my job I you know I
but you're running an organization
though Michael and yeah so medical
records
you got Joelle and beed who's gonna be
upset every agent three agents aren't
gonna trust you
yeah but tougher than me even more than
three agents not trusting and then I
wonder how much free agents trust we're
talking about people that are two
generations younger than us I don't I
don't know how like I want to hear how
big a deal it is to them not not to the
Canadians and the medical information is
the big one to me I mean you your
frickin rules now big ones it's not laws
so that's the one that would concern me
and that's the one that would be more
terrible says look fireable offense now
is whatever offends someone above you
who has control of your career or or how
social media reacts to a story and then
somebody have you reacts as far as the
NBA Finals we were just saying that if
LeBron is this big of an underdog in the
Cavs can we truly be critical of LeBron
no matter what I mean aside from a
subpar performance but if if he gets
swept can we be critical of him that he
got swept if they're one of the biggest
underdogs in team sports history just
looking at two teams now you know
looking at the two teams now and knowing
where they you know how they've gotten
at this point and what happened you know
middle of their season on I would not be
critical of LeBron who I think so far
has had you know one of the if not the
best singles or individual postseason
run that I can remember no no I mean
he'd have to be he has to be dog dad and
Dan I don't think he could one of us or
anybody else feat that happen to doing
no but it almost feels like if he
doesn't get 35 he's somehow had a bad
game out which which is pretty
incredible
but the over-under for LeBron in Game
seven was I think 37 and a half points
and that's a pretty high bar high bar
yeah and look couldn't run out of gas at
this point I guess I mean we used the
term superhuman though it doesn't apply
literally but I mean if LeBron has games
we look he he could easily because he's
done this now a couple of times maybe
maybe in the first series as well he
could average triple-double and they
could get swept yeah I mean our
triple-double with 30 you know 12 and 10
and they get swept and is there any
criticism a legitimate criticism to be
leveled at LeBron I mean only there's
something outside the moon that
characterizes his series but but but in
normal in a normal basketball judging
way where I would I'd be critical of him
is first of all I don't see them getting
swept Golden State is just not engaged
long enough in any series to do that
unless you have a situation like Kawhi
Leonard getting hurt last year and so
therefore they threw out that series but
the Warriors that that's the one thing
that you know while we're gonna start
talking about all-time greatness Dan we
are because that's what we all have to
do and it's gonna be three out of four
presumably we're gonna start talking
about all-time teams and the thing is it
is not engaged long enough they throw
away again yeah I mean the other night
it was interesting to see the Golden
State brass you know at the end of that
game and and all of them were just like
ashen because they couldn't believe you
know the way they were down 15 after
being down 17 the previous first half
and so that's that's what to me will
allow help help with LeBrons own
brilliance being the main thing allow
Cleveland a win or two I just don't see
us week if Cleveland was playing Houston
who would be favored I think Houston
would have and should have been favored
that's a great question Dan but I but I
don't I feel like LeBron could literally
have a chance some of that's based on
Kevin love's help and I'm not one to put
my entire belief in plus/minus
it takes a lot of coaches I know they
don't trust come + - unless you're
considering the five players on the
floor as a unit then you can deal with
Plus - but I think he'd ever look he
would have a better chance the odds
would be different they would still of
course I think favor Houston but not so
dramatically
I don't think anybody will be talking to
sleep and if they won the other night in
Game seven but didn't have Chris Paul
then I think Cleveland could be favored
we had this conversation yesterday and
that is if you were starting your team
and I said you got to pick klay Thompson
or draymond Green starting your - Wow
you got Wow I think I agree I think it
claims it really plays a really good
defender is not like mmm
you know while dream on Green can
probably defend more positions and
people talk about it more even Defensive
Player of the Year once and the league I
think he's been at one time he's been
and he's been like in the top two or
three like three times or more ah man I
think I would take j my dream because of
the number of things he can do in
today's NBA but I think klay Thompson is
probably this it is crazy to think this
could be on the if there's a first team
all underrated I think klay Thompson
could still be on that despite being on
debt for a third championship ring I
think I think that that's you know he's
thought of too often as the fourth guy
and maybe he is maybe he's gonna put him
behind Durant and clearly for sure if
you throw game I agree as you're talking
about the player honestly would you
rather Hank then when it's all said and
done you can have Durant's career Steph
Curry's career well if they wind up the
step winds up with one more ring I'll
takes that's career but it's also his
team Durant came to his team and like
right like it still we give Steph more
credit because Steph helped build this
Durant came over you know once you got
the interior done to your Lamborghini
you know any set in the front seat here
and and I think you agree and you sounds
like you're saying you go I think Steph
will get more credit for for this
dynasty if that's what they have
then then Durant will Durant will be
probably recognized as a better player
like if we do that you know all-time
list
I'm guessing Joe Durant will be higher
than Stephanie Dan we could apply that
so we had that same conversation and I
think where everybody would go okay wait
a minute that's different if he's only
had the Miami Championships who wouldn't
had the better career we stayed in Miami
and they want to say the other times
who had the better career the Brawn of
Dwyane Wade do anyway I ate one first
one without that LeBron joined that
player yeah LeBron doesn't even really
get credit for the Miami titles like a
full title it's like a partial playoff
share where is that's Dwayne Wade's team
and he came there when you join a team
that's already a good team you know
you're just not gonna get credit and I
think people held that against LeBron
they don't give him credit as much as
they hold it against him yeah and I
don't hold it against him I don't I
still you know when people start the
conversation of Jordan and LeBron one of
the things I say is he and it's fine I
had like I had zero when I had zero most
overrated criticisms of all time
well I feel that way about the decision
I still think okay Jordan didn't have to
go and hook up with someone who'd
already won that's it that's a big part
of that discussion for me which I sort
of hate because you have to wind up
being critical of one of the other in
the conversation and it just seems so
unsavory that to me two of the four best
players in the history of the league or
five s whatever you have to criticize
one of them try to make that point to
make the case but yeah wise up the
directory discussion you you wind up
assessing what it's like to be at the
ground floor of something as opposed to
happen on the elevator after a couple of
floors that man we love these lists
though don't we careers and I I have a
more tour
on this Jordan versus LeBron I said I
can't do it anymore because I'm gonna
wait until the bran is done and then we
as an audience in listeners then we can
have a discussion here but until then it
just it seems fruitless and a you know
people holding on to Jordan for dear
life that you know we're not allowing
LeBron to be and he wasn't in the
conversation a few years ago now it
feels like we're actually you could have
open dialogue and an educator you know a
grown-up conversation about it or debate
about it but yeah and look I saw we saw
all those titles with Mike and and I got
to be there with a great seat but you
know I just tell people enjoy what you
see while you can see it and then we can
wait to debate where somebody ranks all
time and until then it just it feels
like it's you're arguing politics people
are gonna tell you the same thing from
their side and they're not changing and
you're gonna tell me your side and
you're not changing as well so why don't
we just wait until it's all said and
done wait we did this the other day as a
topic on the show and I just said to
Frank I saw the weapon sorry that day I
said you know what I'm putting this off
I mean yeah I'm a host of the show and
I'm putting it off but I don't want to
have the discussion and I can't do how
and it's just it's warning me down and
me out and so but you know what we're
gonna if if the Brawn wins a game if he
was one of the first to game that
conversation is gonna come up as much as
that night any of the sidewalk Mike have
fun we'll be watching for your reports
on SportsCenter and tell mr. Tony we
settle oh that's Michael Wilbon for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]